[Nhạc]
Chào mừng đến với Ai/O—trường y kết hợp radio garage. Tôi là Teano.
Và tôi là Ricky. Chúng tôi điều chỉnh bộ nhớ của bạn trong tám phút—không bao gồm thay dầu.
Trong tập thí điểm này, chúng tôi sẽ giải thích Ai/O là gì và tại sao chúng tôi chọn định dạng tám phút.
Chúng tôi cũng sẽ khám phá một khái niệm y khoa quan trọng—SIRS so với nhiễm trùng huyết—và kết thúc bằng một câu đô nhanh.
Vậy tại sao lại tám phút? Nghiên cứu cho thấy não bộ thích học ngắn. Tám phút đủ dài cho một câu chuyện đáng nhớ nhưng đủ ngắn để phù hợp trong chuyến đi hoặc giờ cà phê.
Chúng tôi hứa sẽ mang lại tiếng cười, mnemonics và cung điện ký ức hàng ngày. Nói về cung điện ký ức, hãy bước vào cung điện đầu tiên của chúng ta.
Hãy tưởng tượng bạn đang đứng trong hành lang phòng cấp cứu. Hệ thống phun nước báo cháy phun nước như sốt cao. Đó là SIRS: vòi phun nước (nhiệt độ), tiếng còi báo động (nhịp tim), khói (nhịp thởi), và bộ đồ trắng của đội cứu hỏa (số lượng bạch cầu).
Nhiễm trùng huyết không chỉ là vòi phun nước; nó là vòi phun cùng với một chỗ rò rỉ riện. Có nhiễm trùng và suy cơ quan—có thể nước bị ô nhiễm và đang làm hỏng bảng điện. Đó là cách bạn nhớ đến sepsis.
Vì vậy, SIRS là hệ thống cảnh báo; sepsis là hệ thống gặp nguy hiểm. Hãy hình dung hành lang mỗi khi bạn cần nhớ các tiêu chí.
Sẵn sàng cho một câu đố nhanh? Chúng tôi sẽ hỏi ba câu hỏi. ở lại để kiểm tra câu trả lời trong ứng dụng của chúng tôi sau tập này.
Câu hỏi 1: Vòi phun nước đại diện cho điều gì trong mnemonics của chúng tôi? Câu hỏi 2: Yếu tố bổ sung nào biến nó thành sepsis? Câu hỏi 3: Bạn có thể kể tên hai tiêu chí SIRS khác ngoài sốt không?
Chúng tôi sẽ tiết lộ câu trả lời trong ứng dụng Ai/O. Nó sẽ giữ điểm của bạn—có thể bạn sẽ vượt qua số điểm cao của Ricky!
Nhớ rằng: luyện tập hàng ngày khóa chặt kiến thức. Đó là lý do tại sao chúng tôi phục vụ những bữa ăn vặt lâm sàng mỗi ngày với các tập dài tám phút.
Mời bạn bè tham gia cộng đồng Ai/O. Mỗi khi giới thiệu năm người bạn, bạn sẽ được một tháng truy cập cao cấp—vì học cùng nhau sẽ vui hơn.
Đã đến giờ kết thúc. Ngày mai chúng ta sẽ khám phá một chủ đề hấp dẫn đầu tiên với một cung điện ký ức mới.
Cảm ơn bạn đã lăng nghe! Hẹn gặp lại, hãy giữ ống nghe bên mình và suy nghĩ sắc bén.